frente a esta fundación de acero a unos
30 kilómetros al norte de kiev familias
de civiles ucranianos encarcelados desde
hace casi un año en Rusia se llevaron a
mi hijo y a mi marido el mismo día
vinieron a nuestra casa y se los
llevaron
me dijeron que estaban en la cárcel en
Rusia pero no sé nada más
antes de deportar a 42 civiles de este
pueblo los rusos se detuvieron a unos
100 civiles en esta fábrica por razones
es totalmente arbitrarias la diputada
Ola basibiescas
por ejemplo alguien se tatuó un tridente
ucraniano o un mapa de Ucrania que
incluía crimea otro tenía ampollas en el
dedo y pensaron que esta persona podía
disparar el principal problema de estos
prisioneros civiles es que no están
sujetos a la convención de Ginebra por
tanto no pueden intercambiarse
el 3 de marzo cinco soldados tiraron al
suelo y desnudaron a Basilio y a su hijo
dimitro dimitro es periodista de la
agencia de noticias ucraniana Unión
Él y su padre permanecerán detenidos
aquí durante 10 días en condiciones
infrahumanas
[Música]
esta era nuestra prisión con mi hijo
estábamos tumbados en el suelo
y allí estaba el balde para los
excrementos
cada noche traía nuevos prisioneros
había gente por todas partes
éramos muchos y estábamos muy apretados
nos ataron las manos y nos vendaron los
ojos con cinta adhesiva
se podía ver por debajo Pero de todos
modos no había luz ni de día ni de noche
[Música]
no se le permitía hablar
nos dijeron si hablan les tiro una
granada los prisioneros permanecen en el
frío sin mantas ni colchones
encontramos un barril con agua de la
fábrica para las pilas y bebimos esta
agua
nos dijeron que no nos darían agua
porque ya no había en el pueblo y para
comer a veces nos daban una ración de
soldado
nos lo lanzaron en la oscuridad algunos
lo consiguieron otros no
al final de su Calvario vaciles liberado
su hijo según las últimas noticias
transmitidas por testigos se encuentra
en una prisión al sur de Rusia
esta carta me la envió la Cruz Roja solo
hay tres palabras Mamá estoy vivo
holanena dirige una pequeña clínica en
al norte de bucha cuando Rusia atacó
Ucrania el 24 de febrero está en Primera
fila
el 25 de febrero ya había 40 lesionados
civiles en
esa clínica les prestamos primeros
auxilios Entonces llegaron los ocupantes
y nos echaron han hecho de esta clínica
su base
pero lo peor para olena y su familia
llega tras casi un mes de guerra y
ocupación
el 20 de marzo Estaba preparando comida
afuera en el patio en una parrilla ya
que no teníamos electricidad ni gas un
soldado ruso vino y le disparó a mi
marido lo lesionó en la cadera y la
rodilla
lo tumbaron de un culatazo en la cabeza
le pusieron una pistola en la boca y
otra en la cabeza mi hijo oyó el ruido
salió se arrodilló y suplicó no maten a
mi padre me puse delante de mi hijo para
protegerlo
dejando al abuelo de 82 años en casa los
soldados cargaron al padre la madre y el
hijo heridos en un vehículo blindado
la razón probable
el padre es un policía ucraniano
retirado
tras el interrogatorio nos sentaron en
un pasillo nos pusieron bolsas de
plástico en la cabeza teníamos las manos
atadas
luego nos ataron las bolsas al cuello
con cinta adhesiva
mi hijo me dijo mamá No puedo respirar
nunca había oído algo tan terrible en mi
vida
después de 20 segundos hicieron agujeros
en estas bolsas para que pudiéramos
respirar luego nos llevaron a un furgón
blindado al aeropuerto de antonov allí
sentí la presencia de mi hijo por última
vez
liberada tras Perder el conocimiento
o Lena regresa a casa y espera el
regreso de su marido y su hijo
pasó un mes y medio Entonces el ejército
ucraniano
los primeros días después de la
liberación tuve que examinar todos los
cadáveres en ostomel cada vez que iba
allí esperaba no encontrar a mi hijo y a
mi marido entre ellos y a personas con
las manos atadas a la espalda que habían
recibido disparos en el cuello he visto
tantas cosas impensables que nunca
olvidaré ni perdonaré
[Música]
el 19 de abril el marido de olena
regresó a casa pasó un mes primero en un
campo de filtración en Bielorrusia y
luego en una prisión de Rusia
no reconocía a mi marido perdió 20 kilos
en un mes
cuando llegó a la prisión de kurusk le
rompieron dos costillas en el mismo
lugar golpearon hasta la muerte a uno de
nuestros habitantes de ostomel han
soltado a los perros contra nuestra
gente por qué a mí médico civil me
pusieron una bolsa en la cabeza por qué
golpearon a mi marido un pensionado en
la cabeza con la culata de un rifle y le
dispararon en la rodilla Por qué mi hijo
es rehén desde hace casi un año
al igual que o Lena las familias de al
menos 5000 prisioneros civiles
ucranianos esperan noticias y confían en
el regreso de sus seres queridos